hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sail israels ich
backe heute eine österliche eine oster
torte und zwar hat sich der monat eine
torte gewünscht die sehr fruchtig
schmeckt und frisch schmeckt denn das
normal dass du warst schon der frühling
bald und steht schon vor der tür
und deswegen habe ich eine torte mit
biscuit mit so ein bisschen mit öl teig
gemacht er ist sehr saftig und die creme
ist eine frisch käsecreme aber wirklich
eine richtig lecker frisch käsecreme ich
weiß nicht ob du dich noch an meine
frisch diese wickelt ort erinnert und
genauso ähnliches die creme nur noch mit
etwas himbeeren und mit 40 und das ganze
ist etwas marmoriert und mit kleinen
ostereier nach der krise doppel dient
heute habe ich noch immer noch auf die
hüfte natürlich habe ich jeden tag dann
würde ich in den spiegel und für die
torte muss jetzt zuerst einmal den teig
herrschte mir gesagt es ist ein bisschen
öl teig und dafür zeige ich euch mal den
zutaten für den teig brauche ich drei
150 gramm zucker eine prise salz etwas
vanille extrakt jeweils 100 milliliter
sonnenblumenöl und mineralwasser oder
eine andere flüssigkeit 200 gramm mehl
und ein teelöffel backpulver ich habe
hier bereits auf meine backformen
gerichtet und zwar nämlich drei
backformen mit 20 cm durchmesser und
kann jetzt auch direkt mit dem teig
starten und zwar gebe ich jetzt zuerst
die eier in der schüssel gemeinsam mit
dem zucker einer prise salz und etwas
man den extrakt und dann muss die eier
zucker mischung erst mal für etwa drei
bis vier minuten richtig cremig gerührt
werden
jetzt kann ich die beiden flüssigkeiten
mit dazugeben und an flüssigkeit könnt
ihr jetzt wirklich alles nehmen also
entweder auf wasser nehmen oder ihr
nehmt einen likören in eiliger zum
beispiel oder einen saft oder ganz was
anderes also das bringt dann einfach
etwas geschmack mit in den teig sollte
es nur kurz unteren und dem rest mache
ich dann den teig spanische ich hier
zuerst mal backpulver und mehl
und da kommt das mail direkt mit rein
normalerweise muss es gesiebt werden
aber meinen mädels ganz feines brauchen
und jetzt nur kurz unterheben
jetzt will ich den teig in die drei
vorbereiteten formen
ich könnte natürlich auch auf einmal
packen also in einer form und dann
später einfach durch drei teilen
aber ich bin zur bank muss ich noch mal
etwas gleichmäßiger auf zumindest wendet
den teig gleichmäßig zu verteilen
und jetzt werden die teile im
vorgeheizten backofen bei 200 grad ober
unterhitze für ungefähr 15 minuten
gebracht
die token bilden sind jetzt abgekühlt
einen habe ich jetzt bereits auf eine
tortenplatte gesetzt da kann man auch
eine schöne kleine tortenplatte nehmen
denn die torte ist im durchmesser
ziemlich klein
ich brauche jetzt ein paar zutaten dafür
und zwar mache ich zwei verschiedene
cremes einmal eine pfirsich und einmal
eine himberg rehm als er im prinzip ist
es eigentlich nicht 40 maeva torte und
ich zeige dir euch mal ganz kurz nach
vorne
ich brauche dafür einmal marmelade
himbeer und aprikose jeweils ohne
stückchen und fein passiert dann 200
gramm in ländlichen aus dem tiefkühlfach
204 sich hier die sind aus der dose ein
pc magazine 400 gramm sahne 800 gramm
frischkäse dann nämlich gerne
philadelphia
ich brauche etwas sonderbar 200 gramm
puderzucker und später wenn ihr wollt
könnt ihr eventuell noch die vier sicher
aus der dose nehmen die noch übrig sind
beim frischkäse nämlich immer ganz ganz
klar denn fia in der doppel ram stufe
weil der einfach genug fett hat und ich
finde da schmeckt halt nicht so riesig
und da erinnert sich daneben auch die
konsistenz nicht das heißt falls ihr
frischkäse nehmt empfehle ich euch den
immer ganz gern und ihr solltet auf
jeden fall den doppeln frischkäse nehmen
und nicht fett reduziert denn die sind
einfach nicht so schön fest das heißt
nämlich jetzt das obst und zwar muss das
erstmal verkleinern aber hat kurz im
mixer
und jetzt fühle ich die persische mit 50
milliliter wasser auf dann kommen sie
direkt in einen kleinen topf
und da kommt jetzt ein halbes päckchen
magazine rein und zwar reicht so eine
tüte magazine für 500 milliliter
flüssigkeit und deswegen nur ein halbes
ortes kurz einrühren
dann bereite ich noch kurz dahin werden
vor die werden jetzt auch zu kleinert
und auch mit wasser aufgefüllt
und darüber ist auch ein halbes päckchen
magath ihn ein
und dann müssen die beiden fruchtpüree
es mindestens zwei minuten lang
sprudelnd kochen
das heißt ich koche sie jetzt kurz auf
und dann stelle ich auch wirklich die
uhr und lasse zwei minuten lang
sprudelnd kochen denn wenn ihr das nicht
machen wir die massen später nicht fest
die frucht paris die streiche ich jetzt
noch durch das sieb dann wird die creme
später nämlich richtig schön glatt
ihr müsst es aber nicht machen ihr könnt
auch diese fruchtstückchen gerne noch
mit drin lassen
die frucht platz stets kurz abkühlen und
in der zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal
die islamischen staat schlagen die ruhig
jetzt kurz an und dann kommen da vier
telefonat mit rein
als nächstes gebe ich jetzt den
frischkäse in einer schüssel oder
irgendwie an den schneebesen dann kommt
da der puderzucker mit rein und da gebe
ich dann auch vier bis fünf teelöffel
sein apartment rein
jetzt wird es kurz verrührt also eins
gehören bei acht teelöffel rein denn ich
habe 800 gramm
frischkäse und sagt ihr immer 100 gramm
ein bisschen der saison abgesagt
die zahl gehe ich die creme und teilt
sie auch zwei schüsseln auf
und jetzt ruhig zu der einen hälfte die
vier sich cremes und zur anderen hälfte
die himba creme und damit jetzt nicht
christlich wird macht sich das so
ihr nehmt euch etwas frisch käsecreme
und rührt die mit in das buch pury 1
so kühlt sie nehme ich dann etwas ab und
die kleinen stückchen die geht es da
noch drin haben die sind halt noch vor
sich und dann kann ich die creme unter
die restliche creme unterrühren
und die andere creme für rühre ich jetzt
mit dem himmel püree und da macht sie
das eben genauso immer erst ein bisschen
creme einrühren und dann zur restlichen
creme dazu geben
und jetzt kommt jeweils noch die hälfte
der sahne mit dazu und die müsste dann
vorsichtig unterheben
den unteren tortenboden bestreicht jetzt
wird etwas wärmer lade das bringt ein
bisschen mehr frische in die torte
da kommt jetzt einen tortenring außen
rum und dann streiche ich da schon mal
die hälfte der himba creme drauf
und die bekommen wir am besten mit einer
tankkarte und auch glatt
und wer jetzt noch möchte kann auch noch
depressiv stücke nehmen und die kleinen
würfel
das mache ich mit den alligators
dann kann man nämlich noch so ein
bisschen frucht mit rein geben
dann ist es die zweite tat zu treiben
und stipe streiche ich mit etwas
aprikosenmarmelade
da kommt die hälfte der pfirsich creme
drauf
jetzt mal sie noch die zielsicher
geöffnet hatte
und jetzt kommt noch das zeug deckel
obendrauf und den drücke ich jetzt schön
glatt deckt die torte ab und musste
erstmal für etwa eine stunde in den
kühlschrank und die restliche creme die
decke ich auch ab jetzt auch im
kühlschrank und danach kann ich dann
fertig werden
die tat ist abgekühlt jetzt nehme ich
den tortenring weg und kann die torte
erstmal ganz dünn mit der creme
bestreichen da sie sind im prinzip erst
mal egal welche
und jetzt kommt die dekorative schicht
und zwar gebe ich jetzt hier lauter so
kleckse darauf mit der gelben und der
rosenkrieg und dann streitig die torte
nicht ganz glas sondern die wir dann
erst ein bisschen wellig und dann
vermischen sich die beiden farben auch
ein bisschen miteinander
also da kann jetzt eigentlich nichts
falsch machen
und nehmt ihr eine große also etwas
größere winkel palette ist jetzt die
mittig an und drehe jetzt die torte und
dann bekommt diese leichten marmor
effekt und an der seite mache ich das
jetzt immer so da nämlich ein bisschen
rosa und verstreicht ist am rand und als
nächstes nämlich ein bisschen gelb und
verspricht auch in brand und dann hat
man hier so einen fließenden übergang
jetzt habe ich die oberfläche glatt und
die ränder sind eher so ein bisschen
strukturiert und jetzt kommt noch etwas
glitter splitter drauf und zwar sind es
kleine opladen stückchen mitglieds hatte
geht es in rosa und grün und schwarz und
schwarz finde ich ganz gut warum erstes
papier space papier ist ist ja das habe
ich früher selber gemacht ja und jetzt
gibt es das so chance so mit bisschen
glitzer und ja noch beschluss ist
probleme von svp macht man kann nicht
damit aufhören und in der mitte lege ich
jetzt hier noch so ein paar eier das
sind super ostereier und so haben wir
jetzt dann ganz schnell eine oster
motive oder eigentlich gezaubert und die
sieht gut aus schmeckt gut und ist
wirklich sehr einfach in der herstellung
genau was für dich ja aber dann schaut
die torte das falsche spiel war ist
alles ist die kulisse kann man dann
einmalig ist die masche nicht mehr
das team hat ja auch richtig geschmack
ja das ist ja auch nichts anderes papier
was zerkleinert wurde die rosen
schmecken nach erdbeer und die schmecken
nach ach ja die gibt es eigentlich
überall zu kaufen oder in jedem
supermarkt ja überall so ich stelle die
torte noch mal ganz kurz kühl und dann
kannst du sie direkt probieren
ok
jetzt kann ich die zarte anschneiden der
morath wartet schon ganz gespannt darauf
sagte murat hat sich das gewünscht sogar
auf die idee entstanden ist einfach wir
die maschine
nein die wissen einfach dass ich eine
tolle ehefrau bin und wenn man sich aus
wünscht dann erfüllt ihr natürlich den
wunsch ja aber immer um wir also mit
essen zu tun ja gar nicht und ich muss
aber immer noch den müll rausbringen den
hof fegen das auto aufräumen
ich bin halt eine intelligente ist okay
man gespannt auf eine intelligente frau
etwas richtig tolles gemacht hat obwohl
er jedoch zurück morath sich das und
dann mache ich das wollte sich jeder
ernährungsberatung gesundheits sozial
und so als auch dann die kamera selbst
sagst du probieren also unten habe ich
die himbeere creme darüber eine 40 gramm
und außen herum gibt 40 himberg rehm und
ich finde die torte ist eigentlich
ziemlich schnell gemacht also es ist
zwar optisch mehr schmeckt oder nicht
halten
wenn ich bin ich mit wie joghurt
beschreibt wie die jugend also in yoga
ist ja und zwar schmeckt das ich sags ja
auch recht wie fruchtbar
ja ja ich hab nämlich freundin angelacht
von der creme mir doch mal zeit für ein
nachdem auch nachgemachte mit 512 war
letztlich nicht so auf jeden fall mal in
die kamera sowie ein stückchen ab
wahnsinn
die mcta den teig kann sie ja also ich
finde die torte schmeckt auf jedenfalls
sehr frisch sehr fruchtig und leicht um
diese gitter spielsucht magie einfach
den ja ganz ehrlich super also falls
jedoch nicht wisst was er zu ostern für
eine torte machen wollt oder nicht nur
zu ostern sondern einfach so eine
richtig tolle frühlings torte dann backt
doch gerne diese torte nach
das rezept steht auf zehn.de die kleine
laden schluckauf
ich glaube dass es gleich druck und
süßwaren wie der ganze körper wackelt ja
dann würde ich euch ganz viel spaß zum
nachbacken und wir sehen uns das nächste
mal bis dann tschüss